in the past you have called for the
jailing of CEOs and climate change
Skeptics we've got a clip from 2014 of
you
um let's run that clip and then could
you explain what was your thinking and
whether or not it's changed since then
sure
I think they should be enjoying three
Hots and a cot at the
with all the other
but also are there what about
politicians uh people who deny who
expressed septicism they're selling out
the public trust and you know I think
those guys who are doing the Koch
brothers bidding and who against all the
evidence of the rational mind
are saying that global warming doesn't
exist that they are contemptible human
beings and that you know I wish that
there were a law you could punish them
under
I don't think there's a law that you can
punish those politicians under but I do
I think the Koch brothers should be
prosecuted for reckless and dangerous
absolutely that's a criminal offense and
they ought to be serving time for it
very much appreciate it
okay
um do you still feel that way obviously
we're down one Coke brothers yeah
um you have to look at the the earlier
part of that clip which you didn't show
okay it shows I was being asked a
question about their criminal conduct
the coke energy at that time was I think
it was the third or fourth largest air
polluter in the world
it was maintaining Petco piles in
Detroit and Chicago that were poisoning
uh poor neighborhoods it was it was the
the uh it had been criminally convicted
of violating environmental which means
it did it knowingly in order to make
money
and what I say earlier on the clip I say
if I you know a black kid
from a grocery store you'd go to jail
but why shouldn't the Koch brothers be
going to jail
if there's cells if they're stealing
hundreds of millions of dollars which
was for you do you think people who
because
I do I I have said
that I'm at companies that certain
certain or certain uh entities corporate
entities
that habitually violate the law or whose
purposes they injure the public
um uh public wheel the public interest
those corporations should be subject to
the corporate death penalty and what
that means is there's a there's a um you
know the corporations are licensed by
the states but most of the state's
requirements that the corporation in
order to get a charter
and operate in the public interest and
if it departs from the public interest
in other words if it's completely
consumed by private interest that is
actually damaging the public interest in
the states
the Secretary of State
and the Attorney General have the
capacity in various States
that Charter in every state you know
somebody has the ability and a charter
for example in New York state
in the 1990s
um the Republican attorney general uh uh
liquidated the tobacco Institute
the tobacco Institute was an Institute
that was created by the tobacco by
Philip Morris and the other tobacco
companies
those companies knew for 60 years at
their product was killing one out of
every four of their customers who use
the product as an erected but they were
aligned to the public benefit they were
creating hey let me finish this because
this is important for people to know you
know because I've been accused of this
before
they were the tobacco Institute was
created
to deceive the public about the dangers
of tobacco and it was it was given the
corporate death penalty in New York and
its assets were then distributed
oh uh the Koch brothers at that time
were funding a series of think tanks
that were designed to hide pollution to
to minimize pollution to do things that
were on that were dangerous to the
public and that were fraudulent do you
think that's still the case the First
Amendment does not protect that the
First Amendment does not protect
fraudulent speech if you're if you say
something that is fraudulent you're not
protected so and I do believe
that people who do that should be
punished now
at the time I made that
the Exxon Corporation had secret
documents which we had obtained
it showed that excellent scientists have
been informing the company that their
Sciences with Brad Moses that they knew
more about the fate of the carbon
molecule
and any other scientist in the world and
those scientists that concluded that
global warming was real that it was
going to destroy the Arctic melt the
Arctic and they wrote memos to the uh to
the senior staff
at Exxon saying we if we keep doing what
we're doing we are going to melt the
Arctic and that will be a bad thing for
Humanity it will be a good thing for our
company because there's a lot of oil
under the audience and get at it
so that was the information that I was
dealing with at that time and you know
which was almost a perfect analogy for
what the tobacco Institute so I mean but
do you think that you know do you think
that uh you know organizations that
receive funding from uh you know the
Koch brother at this point should be uh
should be given the corporate death
penalty
and is it is it any less chilling of
speech you know you were talking about
hates back then I didn't believe that I
believe that well you just said that you
were that
that it's the same thing as the tobacco
Institute so yeah
even if they if they were given
if they if they're if the organization
if the purpose that organization was to
deceive the public
and and yeah they should uh did we want
to I mean I I guess just you know on
this question of free speech uh you know
do we want people in positions of power
to be deciding what is acceptable speech
that this is misinformation or mal
information or disinformation
um it just seems like that way Madness
lies because the government will always
come up with a pretext for saying your
speech is not just wrong it's criminal
and you need to be shut down
but I do believe that prosecutors
and judges make decision about what's
wrong all the time and you know we and
we want to preserve that and nobody ever
says that that is a uh you know that
that's an innovation of free speech
right you know what when I say what I
see when I look at that clip and think
of the debate especially in the 2010s
around climate change as I see a lot of
parallels with the kova debate in the
2020s because both climate change and
covid are real and they carry risks to
humans but the reality of those risks
and trade-offs can be more nuanced than
just saying you know just trust the
science or the science is settled and a
lot of those who wanted to have a debate
over the policy agenda embedded in the
climate change discourse or the covid
discourse or suppressed de-platforms
called deniers even called to be
criminalized or asked that I wish there
were laws to Criminal realize this kind
of speech do you regret partaking in
that kind of discourse after kind of
going through this during in the covet
era yeah
you make a good point and having seen
what happened it
if I had known that back then I I
probably would not have made that speech
and also I I see or you know made that
statement
um but I also seen you know in recent
years how you know how the crises have
covered was manipulated and uh and
exploited
by powerful interest to clap down
totalitarian controls and to
um and to you know impose uh
Technologies on people that uh that were
making them profits
for which they own the IPS and I'm
seeing a lot of that now with uh in the
carbon area I'm seeing you know his
emphasis on
geoengineering which I think is very
damaging to the environment I'm seeing
what's happening to the whales off the
east coast of North America
um and you know something that I thought
very long for 30 years of putting those
uh wind turbines out there we have a lot
of wind on land in this country
and we shouldn't be turning the oceans
into industrialized Zone isn't
destroying whales
oh there's a lot of things that I know
now that I you know that I think the
issue is more complex today than it
seemingly was at that point that was an
excerpt from the reason interview with
Robert F Kennedy Jr who's running for
president if you want to see another
excerpt go here if you want to see the
full thing and you should go here
come back next Thursday at 1 pm eastern
time when Zach wise Miller and I will be
talking to somebody that you absolutely
want to hear from